I will never shut up about how difficult
y'all make make it for fat people to
exist oh my God you know what it's like
we're just existing on Instagram okay
we're just and You Adele Adele who no
you know children follow you I followed
you when I was younger like is this
leading with your talent and you have to
think about Guys these are the pictures
that she chooses to give the world this
is how she chooses to represent herself
and she leads with her weight and then
gets mad when people criticize her
weight no it would be one thing if we
were going after Adele back when she was
big getting the most unflattering
pictures of her and making a whole
campaign against it but it's like this
woman this is all over her Instagram all
over
[Music]